d'un point de vue purement collapse aux
logiques c'est à dire scientifique
rationnelle ou dans les rapports qu'on
lisait les publications scientifiques où
on avait déjà dans les listes de choc
systémique
il y avait pandémie clairement c'est est
ce que les scientifiques le prévoyait
enfin certains scientifiques
il y avait des signes avant coureurs
toutes les conditions étaient la
destruction de la biodiversité et
proximité avec des espèces nouvelles
parce qu'on détruit les forêts primaires
interconnexion globalisé des chaînes
d'approvisionnement des transports
tourisme etc
donc on assume et qu'il y avait aussi
des scientifiques salon lassus après
mais qui qui qui prévoyait déjà une
pandémie à coronavirus alors que c'est
la première pandémie à coronavirus que
l'humanité connaît et donc on a
c'était dans la liste des potentiels
risques systémiques globo il y en a
d'autres
il ya des risques climatiques ya des
risques de black out des risques de
pannes d'électricité ça c'est vraiment
un choc systémique
très très dur pour une société et donc
on a des phénomènes de mega
crise en fait par là dessus sur
interconnexion lippert interconnexion
des réseaux globaux des réseaux en tout
cas humains des réseaux techniques et
donc nous on la classe parmi les
étincelles en fête les chocs systémiques
il y en a d'autres ce sera c'est pas la
première ça sera pas la dernière
pandémie et en plus d'autres chocs
systémiques donc on arrive dans un
siècle avec on va subir une augmentation
de la fréquence et de l'intensité des
chocs systémiques qui soit lima tic sur
les ressources sur l'énergie sur le banc
géopolitique
voilà les guerres aussi les famines etc
ou les pandémies et ça fait partie des
paliers des étincelles qui sont capables
de déstructurer le système monde en tout
cas nos sociétés
[Musique]